تحمي بها امريكا منشاتها الحساسه تعهد بيض
بارسالها لاوكرانيا وتعتمدها كثير من
الدول في منظوماتها الدفاعيه
صواريخنا سامز حارس البيت الابيض ومبنى
الكنغرس
منظومه عباره عن نظام دفاع جوي متوسط
المدى صنع بالتعاون بين شركه كونجز بيرج
النرويجيه وشركه رايثون الامريكيه
للصناعات الدفاعيه قدرات هذه المنظومه
الفائقه تتمثل في تتبع الاشتباكات وتدمير
الطائرات والمروحيات وصواريخ كروز
والطائرات من دون طيار
لدرجه ان الولايات المتحده تتخذها درعا
واقيه وحاميا لمحيط سمائها ومجالها الجوي
حول البيت الابيض وزاره الدفاع ومبنى
الكبدول في واشنطن
هذه الصواريخ هي منظومه دفاع جوي متوسط
المدى قابله للتكيف بدرجه كبيره وهي توفر
للمدافعين الجويين نظام دفاع متطورا يمكنه
زياده قدرتهم على تحديد وتدمير طائرات
العدو الحاليه والمتطوره والمركبات الجويه
غير الماهوله والتهديدات الصواريخ كروس
عام 94 قررت الشركتان المصنعتان بدء
التجارب على هذه المنظومه وبعد اختبارات
دامت اربع سنوات دخلت منظومه رسميا في عام
وفي عام 2005 ونظرا لقدراتها الفائقه
ادخلتها الولايات المتحده رسميا ضمن
منظومه الدفاع الجوي
تتكون منظومه من رادار عالي الدقه اضافه
الى ثلاث بطاريات تحمل سته صواريخ جاهزه
للاطلاق بمدى يبلغ بين 15 و 25 كيلومترا
وهي تطلق مقذوفاتها بزاويه 360 درجه
ولديها القدره على الاشتباك مع 72 هدفا في
وقت واحد ما جعل نحو 12 دوله تعتمدها
رسميا في قواتها العسكريه
اعتراضها لصواريخ كروز والمروحيات
والمسيرات واشتباكها مع عشرات الاجسام
الجويه المعاديه في الوقت نفسه وتكاملها
مع انظمه صواريخ باتريت وهوك جعلت منها
اكثر المشاريع الدفاعيه طلبا وتطورا
وتكامل
لقد اصبحت منظومه ناس ورقه رابحه في
الحفاظ على الاماكن الحيويه في الدول التي
تمتلكها وهي مناسبه للعمليات ليلا ونهارا
وفي جميع الاحوال الجويه وهو ما جعل
اوكرانيا مؤخرا تتهافت على امتلاكها من
الولايات المتحده
نحن مهتمون بالتاكيد في التعجيل بتسليم
انظمه الى اوكرانيا باسرع ما يمكن حتى
تتمكن قوات الدفاع الاوكرانيه من التصدي
للهجمات الصاروخيه الروسيه
وبالفعل تم تسليمها الى كياف
ودخلت حيز الخدمه ففي فيديو للقوات
الاوكرانيه ظهرت منظومه ناسيمز تهاجم
بدراوه الاهداف الروسيه
فيما اشارت مصادر اوكرانيه الا ان
المنظومه تمكنت من تدمير اكثر من 100
صاروخ ومسيره تابعه للروس